you keep saying flashbacks but that's
just like she does
yeah yeah I think I think he's asking
about flash drives and is that going to
be a proprietary format or not I think
what we're storing a nun will change
over time we're gonna update it as we go
the day that we have the apocalypse then
whatever is left by the time they can
figure out how to interface it this is
going back to the by the time we need
all knowledge we'll have much knowledge
they're gonna be more advanced than us
or as advanced as we are before they
need it and we're pretty clever at
getting stuff out like I know this is a
paper example but this is how clever we
are the getting the erased manuscript
off of a piece of parchment we're gonna
have that same ingenuity when we're
trying to recover digital and so I don't
worry about that someone can build a
machine well if we can build a thing
that will have draw a hot choc diagram
you know we'll be able to interface with
the flash drive well I mean my
understanding is flash drives they
basically they lose about half their
data just by entropy per 10 years there
are some some of the new some of the
technologies that would be next flash
drives kind of accidentally there their
technology is writing kind of
holographically the way stone does
inside its crystal structure and could
accidentally last for millions of years
but it's only it's it's a market force
that's driving that so that one may we
don't really know what's what's possible
we know that right now it erases to the
point that we can't read it but this
gets back to the crystallography with
the old manuscript there might be a
trace there on a you know on a quantum
level that we're not even aware of yet
yeah and then the question is do we know
to read it and you know that the you
know the rosetta stone was found by one
of Napoleon's soldiers and actually knew
that it was important because they could
see it but you know if you found a
broken piece of a DVD you know it might
be shiny but would you know there's data
on it isn't interesting well what's your
joinder to the language issue because
well no to read these in ten thousand
years and we won't be able to because
he's not gonna be here right well so
yeah I mean the language issue is
reason we the very first long-term
storage thing we did was a language key
right but we don't know I mean ya know
it includes versions of English as well
ten thousand years from now well not yet
now impressive we still have to we still
have you know there's the emoji version
comes next week and Ryan your question
I'm hoping it's protein or yeah I
haven't rolled it i think that's that'll
be the answer like right now digital is
the best thing we have and then the
future to be something better
I love DNA stores and the idea that we
could have a library that is growing and
renewing itself and multiplying but I
know I think a thousand years from now
this is all going to be seemed moot like
of course this is how we do it it's not
gonna be paper though it's gonna be
whatever it comes next
right I think this is Georgia finalized
entire book into the junk DNA right and
actually Jaron Lanier another idea that
durin Lanier had that he's submitted to
the the save a hundred years of the New
York Times project was to put that into
the junk DNA of cockroaches and breed
them endemically and to because they're
you're a population of cockroaches so
you ask me why would someone think to
look into a flash drive but someone's
gonna think to look in the cockroach DNA
first well we spend a lot of time
looking at cockroach DNA
[Music]